I do that what happened let's go jump in
the war and you missed it in where are
you oh [ __ ] there's a something coming I
heard some [ __ ]
there we go I'm like you bro come on
[Laughter]
there's a skeleton and the sunbirds are
on the house
focus our house I put some torches on
the mountain we are on [ __ ] I'm in the
water look in the water I got two
spiders out to me
I'm near the dying here you're nearly
dying
[ __ ] you I got for help
that's it over there
I put a lot of torches on the mouth yeah
you've said that but I can't [ __ ] see
them the better see them
why would fine why is it still night how
the [ __ ] long is in night because I'm oh
I see my old camp now good
I can find my stuff back you know your
stuff is gonna swim here for a while do
you remember yes how is that you make
like a you like ah oh yeah with the wood
yeah I know what are you is sweet I say
because I'm [ __ ] with the English
marina you're just pretending you are
how did you know killing some cat oh
wait no it's not cows it's pig's get
seriously every time I say tractor in
even in Swedish I always think of buses
oh wow it's best I don't know why I
would say that to a bus though what you
know
oh there's a lot of pumpkins over yeah I
got a lot of them as well what's those
green stuff coming out of the ground
that's like bamboo oh you can make books
also I'm gonna take those
well hide that creeper I'm just gonna
take this pumpkins that's me
build a turtle fans I still hear them
okay I should probably do something more
productive after this leave this will be
one episode why don't you jump down in
the cab little cryptic come on what
don't you jump down that these pumpkins
aren't even rare I thought they were
like super rare they are we're having
blue right I see them all the time all
the time well you're lucky I got 14 plus
5 that's 19 it's funny now I dropped the
creeper
why don't you dude wouldn't it be
awesome if you trapped a creeper in like
a glass box and anything could be like
our person all the [ __ ] in our house
or nothing
well it got whoa you scared of what he's
scary good what you okay blowed up
okay I have one half like I got a lot
the bank wait Oh daddy's on the phone oh
it's all right
Kimberly here good
workbench people on the way you're gonna
be like what
now you can barely read it sounds like
yeah exactly
all right no they were it wasn't you how
do I make the boat
I made it you well the mid the left
middle right and then the tree down on
the bottom oh it's a tiny you me yeah I
get it all right I'm gonna head back now
okay this boats even work in multiplayer
yes they do how do I get in it
well I keep like running away from me
but my boat keeps running away from me
oh there we go
doesn't like you yeah okay it's not the
fastest boat but it's mine I gotta head
back now if I can find my way
cooking meat Bella turtle
I wonder what like runs the engine of
this boat
it's like fragrance your or something
well it's really difficult to control no
no it's like different in multiplayer
I got more bamboo stuff over here and I
think that thank you very much my
graphics are pretty bugged there Dave oh
I can't see down there I got to beckon
for you waiting at your home oh thank
get out get out three go oh [ __ ]
we'll ask people what we should build
what is a we should ask people what the
thing we should have been yeah that's
good thing like our script oh oh wait I
want more ripples you got test sama
[ __ ]
wait what Wow it's like confusing I
can't wait
okay if you destroy your boat it doesn't
turn to both right oh no [ __ ] it turns
into wooden man some stick knock
seriously no no no no go down there no
no okay here we go we're back in action
you can't find home can't you yeah
let's do meiosis
why are you in the water and the way
we're not near the water thing is that
this
you're backing up backing up I don't
feel like singing that song cuz my daddy
taught me good he did I'm back in that
hell outta there and I'm like oh my see
if I can fit this hole oh no my post
what the hell my boat destroyed the I
thought they lost forever no if you hit
the luck yeah I noticed
yeah it crashes mother of penis doo doo
let's make two boats cuz I'm not sure if
I'm gonna